hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it is
the twenty-ninth of me today and you are
tuned in to gamespot news first up for
your Thursday let's talk about free
stuff well technically its PlayStation
Plus free stuff so that's free stuff
with an asterisk assuming you're already
subscriber from June on Sony will be
offering up true games per month one ps4
instead of one as part of its instant
game collection because you know the PS
will actually has more than a handful of
games now the timing for free game
delivery is also being switched up so
that all of the games will now be
available from the first Tuesday of each
month so no more constantly checking PS
Plus June selection consists of the
following pixel junk shooter ultimate
and trying to the ps4 NBA 2k14 and Sly
Cooper thieves in time for the ps3 in
the US and the latter is switched out
for lone survivor external Europe
European Vita offerings are dragon's
crown and surge deluxe while terraria
and mutant mudds deluxe will be
available for us gamers let me know
which of these games you'd want most
yeah isn't giving up on trying to get
you guys to fall in love with origin and
the latest plan is to give you
battlefield 3 for free for using the
service the move is a part of their on
the house program which is making the
game available to download free right up
until June good the game is then yours
to keep the comments seem to suggest
that you guys are still pretty antsy
origin and bothered the battlefield 4 is
still somewhat broken but there are a
few of you who are happy to see that EA
is trying to turn things around still
Remedy Entertainment quantum break which
you may remember from such events as
last year's e3 is coming in 2015
microsoft announced that the xbox one
exclusive from the max payne and Alan
Wake crater will launch next year and we
got a new trailer the game follows Jack
Joyce who's trying to prevent the end of
time and the actions you take in the
game will impact how the story unfolds
later in the game and on the TV show yep
there's a TV show in kc for God's Remedy
Entertainment says the game follows
quantum breaks heroes while the TV show
highlights its villains last up the ps4
version of The Shadow Warrior reboot
will be
in 1080p while the xbox one version is
coming at 900p both of them are going to
be running at 60 frames per second
though so that's pretty cool lead
engineer programmer Christoph na kovitch
said Shadow Warrior is a fast-paced game
so it was very important to have 60 FPS
also we didn't want cut any graphic
features so we decided to use 900p with
60 frames per second Shadow Warrior
launched on PC last year and will be
making its way over to xbox one and ps4
this summer let me know if you're
interested to pick this one up and if
you reckon that 180 p resolution
difference is a big deal or not in that
commenting section down below those are
all the things that i wanted to tell you
about today but do remember that
tomorrow I'll have my top 5 gaming
stories of the whole week for you so be
sure to tell me yours and check back
with me then